that there is potential this weekend
in places where vaccination levels are
not particularly high
that there will be a new coke adapt
rates and variance i am
concerned that people who have not
gotten vaccinated
have the capacity to
catch the variant and spread the variant
to other people who have not been
vaccinated
i am not concerned there's going to be a
major outbreak in other words that we're
going to have
another epidemic nationwide but i'm
concerned
lies will be lost and i was even reading
today there's some speculation
some judgment is coming out that you may
be able to even
communicate the vaccine of the
the uh the new uh
variant to your pets so i say not not
totally facetiously for those of you who
haven't been vaccinated because you
don't you don't
you don't think it's you you want to go
through it
it doesn't hurt it's accessible it's
free
it's available and not only don't think
about yourself
think about your family think about
those around you
that's what we should be thinking about
today the fourth of july
to this year is different than the
fourth of july last year
and it's going to be better next year
thank you all
[Music]
okay
good afternoon everybody welcome to the
whitening pre-show i am not waiting to
pray and neither is lea
neither is leah bella but we we're
channeling him right now
uh wayne will be with us in just a
minute uh
welcome to this afternoon the wayne free
show this is probably the greatest show
you'll ever see anywhere
literally worldwide i want to thank rt
our
international audience for broadcasting
us um
syndication as well yeah and if you're
on worldwide because we are
international let us know how the cove
is going over there because
we're getting some pretty interesting
news i mean everything is so conflicting
it's ridiculous so i want to know how
you are actually feeling
also everybody in america share the show
leah blue eyes bella and i'm the one
they call bishop
no documentation on that whatsoever i'm
undocumented
and there's there's the the man of the
hour the great white dupree
what's going on mate i don't think you
can hear
you are live on the way in the pre-show
with wayne
right in the middle of the screen
somebody said dawn acre says y'all look
so cute
thanks don good morning candace i don't
know if that's a good thing or not
everybody's ready to rock and roll
everybody wants the news everybody wants
to know what we're going to talk about
we got a packed show today we got a
couple of
big topics going to talk about uh we're
going to talk about the
music i let me just say can i just say
music is a
very big big deal in our society
when it comes to human nature and music
and
if you're listening to music in the
wrong kind of music
you can be hypnotized into thinking
something that ain't and if you listen
to the right kind of music
well you might be better off go talk
about music that's pretty big
in the news today as well as uh
i know we just finished up the month of
sin
in june and somebody suggested to me why
don't we just keep the seven deadly sins
going
and let's shoot for july the month of
sloth but we're going to kind of push
back on that a little bit
i got got some news i just want to bring
it up and why i keep saying that and why
that that really
has an impact on our kids uh brett
kavanaugh making some news which is
unfortunate along with acb and
if we get to it we might touch because
we didn't touch on it yesterday
but it might touch on a little bit of
alan west making news
as well as
oh biden i don't know if you saw him
over the weekend but he was getting
choked up
at a coffee shop and then uh
some information that we want to bring
to you about uh january 6th
and some some back and forth of how the
democrats are making this
insanely sickly political
what's going on wayne nothing i'm tired
i can see that they make coffee with a
little bit of caffeine tastes real good
i got a lady i'm finally going to a
doctor
next week so we're going to see what's
up
um you need to it's good to have
a doctor's point of view
we this show is being spot the joke dude
not yet go ahead and put that obviously
i was getting ready to put it up there
but if you want to you can
yeah ladies and gentlemen um this show
is being sponsored by my pillow my
pillow dot com
forward slash radio specials um
eight hundred five four four eight nine
three nine
i'm gonna use the code word wayne though
when you do call they're gonna ask you
calling for wayne you can just say yeah
go ahead um their slippers they've taken
about two years to make and produce the
slippers the
moccasins are now out so that's my big
talking point right now because i
actually got a pair
use them every single day people want to
know the quality of them uh quality is
great in fact they're made out of
pretty much the same rubber that my rain
boots are made out of that are to
protect me from the water
so if that's something you're interested
in getting for the summer months you can
walk out on the porch and grill
or maybe you want to sit on your back
patio it's great to have on these
type of uh of this type of footwear
because
it's it's nice it's versatile and it's
also adorable
yeah they're indoor outdoor slippers if
you will and and that's awesome that he
make them that way because you know what
people do do slippers indoor outdoor
whether it be walking out to the mailbox
get the newspaper
walking the dog i see people all the
time walking up and down sidewalks and
slippers so that's a that's a big deal
if you are in the market for a new
mattress
i'm not kidding i know i hear my pillow
advertisements all over the radio
all over the internet everywhere i have
never seen
anybody promote the fact that they have
a mattress
they have a my pillow mattress
with an adjustable massage
usb port uh platform
that fits inside your current
bed frame if you got like a bed frame
like a nice bed frame with a headboard
it sits inside there it is a game
changer
and it's low priced as well so make sure
you use that code word wayne to get 20
off or more just depending on what item
you get yeah the slippers are currently
on the website
40 off my sister's watching
hey sister what's going on
she said um you look sleepy but thank
you sister
we're gonna wake him up we're gonna try
to use right now positive affirmations
here that's a negative
information you look like hell that's
not good don't say that
yeah i i mean this yeah this paint this
um yeah okay um let's see
what does he have up here um aaron lewis
aaron lewis who um
democrat aaron lewis is democrat
slamming anthem
am i the only one leapfrogs taylor swift
on itunes
he's a country western singer and he has
come up with a song
that if you listen to the lyrics of the
song it really
it's what we're all thinking there's
nothing new
about it it literally is what i'm well
everybody is thinking
and the lyrics just go uh am i the only
one here tonight
shaking my head thinking something ain't
right
is it just me uh am i losing my mind am
i standing on the edge
of time uh seriously who here is not
watching
any kind of news whatsoever and saying
holy hell
is this really happening yeah um
i so to answer your question i
ended up going kayaking over the weekend
and
yeah and here's the thing i will tell
you when you said is anybody watching
the news and film the same way
that morning i woke up it was sunday
morning i think i woke up and
literally had to rush out and go
kayaking there's no
internet and even if there was you don't
want to have your phone out in the
middle of the river right guys
so i'm there for like four hours and
then i get home and i'm exhausted take a
shower and take a break
and i'm like why do i feel so good today
why do i feel
not so negative and i'm like wait a
minute it's because
i didn't watch cnn i didn't watch msnbc
and i didn't get on twitter and see eric
fangeldang or whatever you say his name
that
scaremonger for the left pushing the
covid vaccines
i didn't see any of that on sunday and i
thought
wow really is this how some of america's
living
stress-free and not dealing
with seeing all this propaganda look
there's a difference between their show
and our shows our show i try to give you
hope and we try to give you
think outside of the box ideas and
opinions not just history lessons
and not just talking points at least i
hope so but
that's what they're doing they're
fair-mongering and they're giving you
what they think is their history lesson
along with talking points i've had
enough of it i'm not going to mainstream
media anymore
go ahead wayne yeah well thank you
well i can tell i kept on interrupting
cause i was like
no no i mean i i'm trying to remember
i don't think i
listened or watched any news on sunday
and you were in a good mood weren't you
yeah
yeah you were making chicken yeah yeah i
was barbecuing and
you know i was i was hanging on the deck
and
i mean i stayed on the deck for mostly
mostly the whole day so yeah i mean
you're right you're right about the news
type of thing
um i mean believe me if you're trying to
raise your spirits you ain't running the
news
no you're definitely not i mean i
remember when i was growing up
most of the um you
the six o'clock news you could tell
exactly
what they were doing they would start
off with
national news that was just
down it was down all the time first
story
no matter what and then they would like
the top
like maybe the top two the top two
stories
and then weather would come and then
they would come with another
local uh
bad story and then there were inch in
sports and then they would
sometimes sometimes they would
sometimes they would talk about local
good things but that was always at the
end though
right if you're in baltimore i was in
baltimore in the 90s and when i was
watching the local news it wouldn't be
it would be death the
shootings around the local area
cincinnati not so much we had to pull
stories from other cities but anyways
they still had to talk about death
death is this uh it's this
inevitable thing obviously we're all
going to die but it's this fascinating
thing
that the media has that they absolutely
must must talk about death at all cost
because it's so fascinating and so
whatever and it gets people into
watching and the fear-mongering the
whatnot
and uh you can see what they did with
the coven i mean the ratings through the
roof and everybody's talking about death
every day all day knocking on your door
it's about here it could be here
you could be next i suggest
it's rare to die from copenhagen what
brian did you really say that
yeah i said it well i mean you got
you got something up here about the
fourth job fourth of july weekend
yeah this kind of went hand in hand it's
just conservative versus
we i know we talked about cory bush but
hand in hand it goes with
you've got conservative
uh mute country music stars that are
coming out that really love this country
kind of a juxtaposed then all of a
sudden you got and they talk about good
things about
things that are happening things that
are possible you know what the country
means to them
and and how it's provided and think
about it we live in a day and age where
we literally want for nothing you can
love communism all you want kids
but i'll tell you right now give up your
iphone give up your ticket tax
give up all that stuff then you can have
your communist
you won't do it but yet you've got
people like corey bush that we talked
about yesterday
that uh that black people still aren't
free and
it's the juxtaposed it's the opposites
and we live in the same country and how
is that possible
and again you got chicago's
can y'all hear me yeah again chicago's
bloody fourth
of july weekend you got uh 92
no 92 92 shot
is that right i lit him up this weekend
in chicago
i always feel here's my issue with
chicago i feel like democrat
officials people in office that are
democrats
they like us when we talk about chicago
because um it takes the heat off of them
takes the heat off in new york city
portland austin san francisco
uh chicago chicago i think that um
chicago
is a bad baseline to say how bad crime
is i think chicago crime is more related
to
gun to gang violence than it is anything
else but what's happening in other
cities
like austin texas like new york city
like portland uh are all because of
defunding the police and bad policies uh
and i think that that's that's where the
problem lies
chicago's got some wretched policies
with a wretched mayor who sure
who claims that 99 of our negative news
is because she's black and gay
the only reason why i think that chicago
seems to be popping up
is somebody has created a website a day
by day
hour by our website that literally
tracks and documents
shootings deaths how they occur cops
versus people
and so it's very intuitive hey
jackass.com
uh if you go down the list of different
cities
st louis is the worst city chicago
only ranks about like 10 11 12. st louis
is the worst
east saint louis per capita
is the worst hands down across nation
but they're all democrat-run cities well
it's interesting
that more people die more children died
over this weekend due to shootings than
covet
yeah yeah and what does that
mean you know i found in um doing and
doing some research i found
this uh like if y'all want to check this
out this is gun violence
archive dot o r g
um gun violence archive dot o
r g and i didn't even know this was out
there but
this talks about the shootings and um
how many were injured how many were
killed
where it happened uh
like in california roads let's say
today's the six
to six yesterday three people were
injured one person was killed
um chicago yesterday no yesterday four
people were injured two people were
killed
uh in in brian's ohio 11 people
uh injured one person killed where they
say dayton
i think columbus i think there are 11
shot in cleveland just in a matter of
fact cleveland's about
i live in cincinnati we don't even claim
cleveland this part
well no this is toledo this is oh
tortoise
toledo's up there close to cleveland
that's that's a little bit up there
up north yeah yeah so you had um
two you had two major things in ohio
um over there over the fourth of july
weekend um so
i mean this whole thing like dallas
illinois and it almost goes back to the
breitbart
virginia georgia pennsylvania north
carolina
uh i i'm and and the illinois
is filling it out on here too but this
almost goes back to
what um what breitbart was saying
yesterday
which now bro uh
uh brian said uh 92 were shot
16 fatality
uh i'm not sure yeah those numbers i
mean
yeah the thing is somebody says in the
chat i like how we're talking about
fear-mongering and how the news talks
about death and then we're discussing
death we are discussing death but we're
not trying to scare the hell out of you
what we're trying to
wake up your eyes alex is by saying we
joe look i'm going to call spade a spade
joe biden is ruining this country and
why do i say that
because it was not like this with trump
and it wasn't like this prior to that
joe's turning a blind eye he's letting
this happen and i just truly don't
understand why i've got people
on the democrat side telling me the same
thing that joe is really hurting this
country
by not fixing anything because he still
has this grudge
because of trump they can't get over
trump and that's the issue
when you're sitting there trying to
defund the police but then you have your
same side saying no
joe's saying to fund the police and then
you've got sack of potatoes press
secretary come out
saying the republicans are trying to
defund the police this isn't
a healthy talking point this isn't a
healthy america
okay when your president doesn't have a
clue and your press secretary lies
through her teeth
we've got major issues here and we're
coming off the heels
of this insanity of locking down an
entire
locking down the world but locking down
down the entire country for an entire
year
and fear-mongering telling people to
stay in their houses they're going to
die now we look back
over a year and a half we realize um
pretty much damn near hoax we shouldn't
have locked down
shouldn't have locked down the the
economy shouldn't have locked down
people
suicide raised to the roof anchors
through the roof uh
alcoholism's through the roof people are
doing stuff that they shouldn't be doing
uh all out of frustration and anger
because
of some insanity to to lock people down
and and this is the administration this
is their policies this is what they want
and this is how they take more and more
more control and as they're talking
we've brought it up here on the show
before
i saw him with my wife this morning she
hadn't heard about it uh
i guess she hadn't watched the show but
the delta variant
is just it's capitalized can't let it go
don't let the coven go no no we got
delta coming
coming for you go get you well i mean
i think that mental health plays a large
part in all of this
and i think that that's one thing that
joe biden will not speak about because
they don't know how to handle that uh
the only thing that they can
talk and say is we need to get the guns
we need to get the guns
when really you're still going to have a
lot of mentally ill people and they'll
i think that causes you outweighs first
like they've done before
um real quick real quick before i
um before because uh there's a lot of
topics on that
on the thing uh if y'all want to check
this out
again um it's the gun violence archive
gun violence archive.org um
and uh as i said they counted 375
shootings
over the fourth of july weekend at least
140 people
died from gun related and violence from
saturday to monday
the tally includes 18 shootings with
four or more
victims four or more victims the return
of mass shootings in america was felt
over the fourth of july as cities from
chicago to lancaster pennsylvania to
fort worth texas
uh so the i mean again this is not
trying to
fear put fear in you but as
a as breitbart was saying at least in
four cities
uh uh shooting violence has gone up
50 especially with the defunding the
police and in liberal policy
these are liberal policies and liberal
ideologies that the democrat party has
completely and totally embraced
yeah so uh washington post
uh washington post um kids
should watch portrayal of sex acts
at pride parades okay
washington post i don't know if that's
gonna
help anything well actually no that's
from life lifestyle news
so liveset news was quoting the
washington post uh but they were talking
about for many lgbt
activists uh uh the in innocence
is the enemy at least and now at least
they're being honest about it
we've got these uh parades at least when
i lived in
southern california down long beach they
would have these parades on a regular
basis they would have billboard signs on
the freeway
uh billboard signs everywhere a half
naked man holding half-naked band
dressed up s m noesnam
flag cup what whatever i mean it's just
it's it
it it it's not my thing kind of kind of
grosses me out
i don't want to see that and we had two
two young daughters under the age of six
at the time and we both agreed
you know what we don't want to raise our
kids in this environment
this is a toxic environment and we want
to keep the innocence of our children as
long as we possibly can
psychologists at least when i was
re-raised
said the longer that you can keep your
child's innocence
the better decision-making processes
they make
as adults less promiscuity
which leads to all kinds of craziness
whether you want uh stds or hivs and
lmnops uh you know you can stay away
from that kind of nonsense
uh but but now this is nationwide
they they want this in everybody's home
and everybody's place
everywhere and now having
sex in an inappropriate
and an abusive way is now a right well
i tell you know i'm so glad that my
girls
well they think well they're gonna have
to
they're gonna have to deal with this in
college i hope not
or i'll pull them out um
you me i'm carrie my niece was pressured
into things that she didn't want to do
in college it gets worse in college
that's where it
starts that's why they're i will be
honest
this whole lbgtq movement probably
started in
college hallways in classrooms just to
let you know you know
you know i look i i'll i say this
without any prejudice
um if they
i mean they've already pushed it on the
american people they said that they
weren't they said that they weren't
trying to but they did
that's just the truth of it they did
they push a lifestyle it's a
trip to me to me i mean i have to call
it a lifestyle because i don't believe
that god creates a mess
i i mean i'm a i'm a i'm a christian
straight up i know what the bible says
uh now i don't come on here preaching i
don't come here telling that you're
wrong
i i'm not i could though i could i could
bring out scripture
all day long and tell you exactly what
god says
but you know what teach his own you you
have
your relationship with whoever you pray
to and i have my relationship
with jesus christ however however
you're not gonna i mean if you ask me my
opinion about
this lgbtq lmnop type of stuff and
deuces and whatnot i'm going to tell you
i ain't for it
i'm not i'm never in for it i don't
support it i don't
i don't i am 100 against it
now am i going to get up in your face
like a like i said no i ain't going to
get up in your face
nah nah i'm going to start in a fight i
ain't going to
i'm going to make no furniture move
however however though
you know you start pushing that stuff on
my kids and you
you start getting my kids face then you
know
there's there's going to be a revival
there's definitely going to be a revival
and
and i mean if you're part of the old
southern baptist churches or pentecost
you
you about to see some dust come up from
the floor
you know and i mean that's that's just
the way it is
but don't be angry at me well i mean you
know what you can be angry at me all you
want to
but i'm saying for what i believe in
again
i'm not mad with you for believing that
you want to
be doing this mess right
yeah it's you yeah just don't shove it
down my throat but don't get mad with me
yeah if i don't support it because i
ain't
right you ain't gonna bully me into it
because i've been bullied by the best
and that was in elementary school dude
i'm i'm an adult you know
you're not bullying me anymore yeah we
went from norman rockwell's america
to hugh hefner's america like like
literally
i mean i mean it's everywhere all day
everywhere whatever you want
uh there was an article i was reading
earlier today that a girl a teenage girl
uh was at a the museum or whatnot and
she said she identified as a boy
went ahead took her took her top off and
started walking around
going in the bathrooms and the museum
supported her rights uh to do that
at whatever age this is nuts
shelley says our middle school is
wanting to start an lgbtq
school club these kids are like 12 years
old there's no business for this in
schools i agree
the problem with it is again it goes
back to mental health
everything in this country's issue
except for the border
goes back to mental health there's
something wrong with you if you feel
like you are a man trapped in a woman's
body
you need to be psychoanalyzed first
before you just go
chopping off stuff and then parading
around in the streets of new york cities
with a rainbow colored flag
it goes much deeper than that just like
how if you would get a surgery for your
stomach to be stapled for you to lose a
hundred pounds they psychoanalyze you to
make sure that you're not mentally ill
and just doing this
to do it you've got to be able to check
yourself before you wreck yourself
yeah look deborah says it's very hard
dealing
with gay transgender grandson i love him
but him totally against it what
but what am i gonna do hey listen you be
you
it just be that rock yeah i mean you
know what how is this hate speech
someone says that this is homophobic
borderline history
yeah yeah yeah yeah no not not at all
it's not
hate speech at all it's what you hear
with your ears and if you hear hate
speech then it's you so
you know what else is hate speech trans
people
telling you not to say nothing
telling you keep your mouth shut or
behind
don't yeah or don't respond to the way
that um that they act however but they
can respond
forget about that deborah listen um it's
very hard dealing with chris
uh look if there's one thing that
uh that i saw from my grandparents
is they they love you you know they love
you
you know they tolerate you but there's
just certain things that
you probably don't do around ground
because brent ain't going to tolerate it
you don't say okay don't talk about it
yeah no no i mean
and and children will get that
from their parents or their grandparents
if the gran i mean if their grandparents
or parents
are are fully uh um um
stern on you know i love you
i don't agree with it but you know i
love you if you need me i'm here for you
i'll help you but this is where i am
also deborah respect me too right
deborah it's also a good idea to
have an open conversation with them
whenever they feel comfortable
by asking them what made them feel this
way
and why you might have to ask some
uncomfortable questions like did someone
in the family
sexually abuse them um
things like that because honestly a lot
of transgender
are suicidal and they come from either
sexual abuse or physical abuse
and get to the root cause of why they're
doing this there's a cause of everything
you just don't wake up one morning and
say it
uh there's a cause for everything so
instead of putting a band-aid over it
with a rainbow-colored band-aid let's
get to the real reason why you feel like
you're non-binary because putting this
rainbow-colored band-aid on everybody
and just allowing for example demi
lovato to do what she's doing
she's had three strokes she's had two
overdoses
she's not she she'll tell you she's
mentally ill and now she also comes out
and tells you she's non-binary there's a
correlation there there's a connection
there
let's start making it and let's start
having those uncomfortable conversations
with our kids
who has touched you did someone rape you
did something happen to you that you're
not telling me
those are the questions we need to talk
you know uh michelle
michelle you you're right my son's in
their 30s they don't swear or drink in
front of grandma and she doesn't improve
why there's a level of respect
you you don't do it in front of grandma
and for
and for some parents who still have that
respectability out there you don't do it
in front of your parents either
um wow look what debra put he was
sexually abused by the neighbor boy
and tried to commit suicide many times
see you guys there
i i talk to your child if they think
they're transgender
talk to them see who has been touching
them see what they
saw because i'm telling you they're
trying to escape
what they felt a lot of them have been
sexually or physically abused
that's where it starts it's not being
taught in school
how to tell people if you're being
sexually physically abused but it's
being taught
that it's okay to be transgender please
you guys talk
to your kids and watch who they're going
around right they're teaching that
they're loving the worst in people and
what i mean by that
is that the worst that bad thing that
happened to you that's in you
they're actually loving that and telling
you that
that's now you that bad thing that was
done to you that's in you
and now the confusion that you're having
in your mind and and
all these issues you're having like no
that's normal you're beautiful you're
great
continue on that road and that road
leads to an
absolute wrecked life a wreck situation
there's so many videos now that are
coming out that i absolutely applaud i
always thumb them up and i share them
uh ex gay individuals ex-trans
individuals that have found god that
have found christ and have found a way
out
of the roller coaster ride that is that
lifestyle
i i like very fair like terry says it
always comes back to parenting
and true truth and the structure that
you have with your grandparents
included well if they're still alive the
structure that you have with them
because
again i never cursed in front of my
grandparents
and i and and i was on my best behavior
in front of my grandparents you know why
because i respected my grandma
to the point she's she's been here
longer she knows a whole lot of stuff
i could talk to her now she didn't she
probably didn't agree
with me touching the girl's bottoms you
know what i'm saying
you know for real she she didn't agree
with that wayne
no don't do that you mean
like slapping them and whatever that's
okay
it just sounded weird to say it that way
that's i was just clarifying wait
when i was well you know when i was a
kid yeah kid yeah we screwing around
like i wouldn't turn on i used to listen
to metallica back in the day when i was
a young kid i wouldn't turn that on when
grandma's at the house
you would play that stuff you wouldn't
do that in front of her
and see now i love these comments and i
just want to explain
this and and this is exactly what uh
is wrong with the world uh someone said
if you're looking
i feel like you're looking for a reason
to uh understand someone when you don't
understand i know a lot of people who
were assaulted or abused
and they did a lot of soul searching
before they came to this conclusion
of their sexuality that weren't
assaulted or abused now
that is true too but they also may have
eating disorders
they might they might have other
mentally uh
mental issues that weren't addressed so
it all goes back to mental health so
again
uh if you're only listening to 50 of it
you might not pay attention so that's
why i'm trying to explain
that yes it could be sexual abuse mental
abuse but it also could be stemmed from
an eating disorder a chemical imbalance
you need to ask your friends yeah you
might not be sexually abused but what
else is going on in your life
there's a reason why transgender people
have the highest suicide rates
i have to call a little bit of bs on
that one
if you're trying to tell me unless
you're in the profession as a
psychologist
that you've interviewed people wide
range of people
that have not been abused that aren't uh
trans
or lesbian or gay and you're making that
statement you
you you better be some kind of
psychological uh a doctor that's
in the thick of it helping people out
and if you were
then you would know that there's massive
amounts of abuse even in the
relationship
i lived there for almost 12 years the
relationships are volatile
there's a lot of alcohol a lot of drug
use and a lot of violence in those
relationships don't tell me there's not
and it's hilarious decades because the
response is actually 99
of them are psychologically sound good
mental health is is a lie
there's no such thing you have no idea
what's going on behind closed doors
everybody has some issue
so again that conversation now you can't
i guess you just can't talk stupid out
of somebody
so again um this is not a closed-minded
conversation if anything yes i agree
with you it's an open mind conversation
i'm not saying that they can't do what
they're doing i'm just saying
please make sure that there's not
another issue and you're all saying that
it's a close-minded conversation are the
ones that are showing up
to the funerals of the transgender
people going what happened
why'd he die i thought he was so happy
he was just walking new york city with
the flag
and a penis on his head and i thought he
was happy why did he kill himself
it's because you don't get why he's
transgender you don't get
what issues he's having deep inside and
a lot of people go to the lbgtq
community
because they feel lost because they
don't know where else to go because
they're not getting good mental health
because our government's not addressing
it and our hospitals don't know how to
deal with it so you got a lot of lost
people out there
joining onto this movement just like blm
and just like antifa because they're
being accepted into it
instead of being helped that's the
problem
and also because you know we we also
have some more
things um on the list but uh it also
just go back to what terry said oh it
all comes down to parenting too
in the last two generations parenting
sucks
parenting has gotten to the point that
they are the drop em
drop em off kids at the at the uh day
care center
and then just they just go and do
whatever they wanna do or the parents
wanna be
the kids friends instead of kids parents
they
they aren't teaching kids anymore they
are
putting up and and and then
actually all our parents aren't even
showing love to their kids anymore
they're they're abusing them that's why
you see so many kids
um uh being uh molested
or uh kidnapped killed
uh hell for ransom or i mean
you have so many things happening to
these kids today
because parents aren't being parents
i mean you you have to go back to three
or four generations ago where
parents were parents parents parents are
parents parents they went out
they worked hard they came back they
whipped your ass if you did something
wrong
but they also hugged you when you did
something right you know that
there's no more teaching well actually
i'm sorry there is some teaching still
going on with
kids with parents that care about their
kids
we still have that but the majority
of parents today are so self
think about their self so much they
pick up the kids at school they get home
and they don't see the kid for about
three or four hours and yeah they're too
busy on the internet
um food they don't even put the food on
the table anymore it's on the stove and
then they go in the room and then
they're on their computer
uh or or order video games and you know
the kid is left in their room
talking to themselves creating new
people and all that stuff and everything
i'm gonna win i'm in here heroin and
fentanyl hasn't helped that either i
made a comment to a single mom
and single parenting is
it's got to be almost impossible i've
never been a single dad
um thank god uh but i know a lot of
single parents
a lot of single moms and i can see the
frustration
i can see the anger i can see the
despair i can see that you have to work
mom you have to work a full-time job
and then come home and then be a
full-time mom
and if you got a couple of boys and
you're a mom
now it's exponentially even worse
because those boys need a dad they need
a strong male dad role model
to tell them hey boys hey get that out
keep playing around
put screwing around and diane when you
don't have that and you have just that
single mom
it's too easy to just walk away while
they're eating dinner and you go in the
other room on your phone
it's easy to walk away and let them be
on the phone it's easy to completely
disconnect
from them and and i mentioned to this
individual i said you know what
you need to eat with your kids every
night and they said well i i don't
i wasn't hungry irregardless it doesn't
matter
you need to sit there and you need to
look at them and you need to talk to
them you need to engage them
i'm just this is what kids need kids
need an adult like authority
with good authority that's patient
that's willing to listen
and willing to be there for them on a
daily basis
and another mundane questions it's the
same questions over and over again i
know now you know it gets frustrating
with
that's what kids need and that's where
the patience comes in
something that kids don't need maybe the
vaccine
that was our headline they did not need
that there are now
countries pressuring anti-vaxxers to get
vaccinated right uh have you heard about
this
yeah i i'm this is this is this
something
this is something that i saw and i did
want to bring out
but um there are some countries out here
right now that are pressuring
those that have not gotten the vaccine
to get vaccine
uh and i you know actually i'll start
off i'll start off in the united states
the city of san francisco has announced
it will require
all municipal employees to be vaccinated
or they could face
penalties penalties and including
dismissal the new rule would not take
effect until the vaccines have been
received
well until they have received full
approval from the u.s food and drug
administration
but more than 150 employees and i
remember reading this
um a few weeks ago uh at the houston
methodist hospital have already been
fired
because they have not um
complied with getting lawyer up
that's a violation of the constitution
in italy uh uh a group of three
300 italian workers have gone to court
to try to get the obligation turned over
and a hearing is scheduled on july 14th
in britain
um the british government announced all
that all care home staff in england
will need to be fully vaccinated there's
nothing you could do in britain
you've got i mean that's just it they're
gone that in canada
the weird part is people are still
getting the virus
with the vaccine and some over 50 are
actually
dying so can you actually categorize
this as a vaccine
or is this a strong therapeutic because
in my definition book
uh it says that vaccines stop viruses
and and and that's another thing too so
many um
cnn and i don't know why they are still
being allowed to do this
but cnn is claiming and and they say
you get the virus so that you won't get
covert but we keep on getting stories of
people getting coveted
after they get the vaccine so i mean and
they keep on doing it they keep on doing
that
here's my question also uh i'll
go back to that eric fangeldang or what
i can't i don't know his name's eric he
says
on twitter that uh getting the vaccine
means that you won't be a long hauler
well if you get the vaccine and then you
get covered you could have vaccine side
effects
and covered long hauler effects that's a
double whammy that you're giving your
body
i can't imagine getting both that would
be absolutely exhausting
my thing is have you heard anybody
that's had coveted recently
get re-infected with covid see they're
not talking about that
they don't want to talk about that
that's something i'm going to do with
joe biden and i'm going to whisper
well because they don't they don't want
to they don't want you to understand
that you have t cells and b cells that
will allow your body to shield itself
from the newer covid variants which is
probably more protection than the actual
vaccine
and one last thing and then i'll let you
go brian my question is this
those that i'm seeing famous people or
people with check marks on twitter come
out saying
we had the vaccine in april and we just
got covered again
we lost our taste of smell we're stuffed
up we have headaches we have fevers
but we didn't go in the hospital well
how the hell do you know you wouldn't
have gone in the hospital anyways
and guess what their kids didn't get the
vaccines and they didn't end up in the
hospital
so again how do you really know
something's working if you never had it
to begin with to test to see
where you would be at i don't know i i'm
really starting to get skeptical with
these vaccines considering it just came
out that it's only 64
effective uh the pfizer vaccine there's
not enough studies i'm sorry
there isn't just being truthful you have
um the vatican
italy britain russia
kazakhstan united states france saudi
arabia pakistan
they are all uh coming up with
mandatory vaccinations they are trying
their own military
they are trying to pressure these
countries you're in the military you
can't do nothing about that you're going
to get it
it's mandatory starting sometimes you
want to get it in the military you're
going to get it
whether you know it or not it's going to
happen a gop
a gop senator or representative is
fighting that right now
he is fighting for
military employees of
being forced the vaccine right now i
think that should be
also informed of what vaccines you're
getting when we were in basic training
there's no list there's no paperwork and
if there was paperwork it wasn't privy
to me
why'd you
i tell you what if they put something in
you
and you find out i'm sure i'm sure
if you get the right lawyer that you can
get him in trouble no it's gonna be
still hard to fight
well no no it might be hard with the
military because you
because you sign in a whole lot of
documents so you don't read everything
there's
so much paperwork that's insane right
but um if something does happen to you
you can claim it you can claim at the va
you might not be on the the earth long
enough but
you know you your your uh your uh your
dependents might be able to get
something from it um
vaccine numbers real quick we are
currently what cdc is reporting
currently over over 300 000 might be 400
complaints and um issues
having to do with the vaccine itself
everything from hospitalizations to just
actually filing a complaint that i'm
having an allergic reaction to
the vaccine to the point to where we're
now cresting
very close to almost 7 000
deaths yes are related closely to the
vaccine
people are posting their stories online
i mean we're living in the day and age
where technology is at our fingertips
and we're able to share stories
instantly with people
and now we're starting to see everything
from rare
palsy to heart enlargement to brain
issues all kinds of side effects that
are happening that are having to do
with this experimental experimental
drug well here total adverse effects
as of yesterday about 400 000
deaths seven thousand pregnant woman uh
with adverse events over two thousand
bells pulse b
palsy cases four thousand allergic
reaction a hundred and fourteen thousand
blood clotting disorder seven thousand
uh heart inflammation over fifteen
hundred that was just in the last 36
days
i think um age range coveted versus the
flu shot when it comes to adverse
reaction
16 people in the age group of 6 to 18
uh had an adverse reaction with with the
flu shot
coven 19 467.
okay so i mean it's a it's a huge number
it's a huge number with
it it's out shine it's outshining if you
will any vaccine that we have out there
yeah he's out doing it and it's
attacking the negative way right
it's out doing it in in such a negative
way
um and and now on top of that for a des
for
for a virus that you're at worst
97 survival rate and
we're talking now for as for delta and
now there's a new one coming out called
lambda
i think if i'm saying that right lambda
variant coming out of peru
um i don't know i don't i don't know but
uh
there was just a tweet put out by the
fearmonger who said that northern
scotland's largest hospital is now on
code black after reaching capacity
uh amid increasing delta variant cases
in isolation
so he's saying that that's worse than
but what he doesn't tell you is that
they're low staffed
and that everybody's over 50 or 60 with
comorbility see
so you don't get the whole story before
we before we get to alan west
is this idiotic that you think that we
shouldn't lift restrictions
at all on the line that we should carry
on exactly as we are is am i right is
that what you're suggesting
well lifting restrictions will increase
transmission
and with all the problems that i've just
talked about
it doesn't seem to me the best time to
do that
if you remember a few weeks ago we
actually postponed
lifting restrictions because the
situation was so serious
but the situation's even more serious
now isn't it what's that
it's so stupid it is stupid i recall a
little bit of it
it said that um she said that you
remember a week ago
when we had restrictions that things got
worse
when we kept the restrictions in place
and now and and now but but you're
saying that
with the restrictions in place things
got
worse so why would you do that but
you're saying you're against lifting
with the restrictions
because things are going to get worse
but things got worse
when you kept restrictions in place look
i'm gonna tell you this and i know this
might be hard for a lot of
uh liberals in the audience and if you
wanna share this with your liberal
friends go ahead
delta's coming for you it's highly
contagious it is i'm not gonna lie about
that
prepare your body no one is going to
escape this i don't
care if you get the vaccine or not
you're going to get coveted
i promise you and you're going to and
the likelihood is you're going to
wilkins we're going to get covet joy
you're going to get coveted
everybody is going to get covet it's a
highly contagious invisible
flu-like virus y'all are going to get it
everybody's going to survive repair your
body you'll get it
everybody's going to get this just
prepare your body that's all you can do
now if you've already had it you may get
it again it just might be
less likely that you'll get a sick but
accept the fact it's invisible it's
invisible
we're not gonna lock down again i can
promise you that i highly recommend
all right don't worry about it i hope to
god not um and i will say this though
if you want to take preemptive measures
get in shape
yeah prepare your body raise some weight
because currently
they're saying that the folks that are
uh
on the older end higher end heavier end
they're the people why can't liberals
just accept the fate
the fate is you're gonna get it just
suck it up and get ready because they've
been feared that this is death
this is interesting it's no different
than strep throat
they died let's talk now let's talk
about both sides of the coin though
what did you say about liberals again i
don't understand why they're
so afraid when they know inevitable
it's an invisible contagious virus but
how do you escape that
but then you have people on the other
side that says oh this is fake
i i won't say it's fake i can see it for
my eyes i've had
it i know it's not right but the
reaction to it is is
a complete hoax well for right but
for one side you say i mean for one side
one side is saying hey this this whole
thing is just being blown up out of the
water but then you're saying
the other one i'm saying this blowed up
out the water i'm saying that yeah
but then but then you
chastise the other side for what the
other side is thinking too
well see i don't i don't listen to
stupid people that say that it's fake
and that it's not real because i've had
coveted
so it's real that's what i was talking
about
can kill you if you have comorbilities
or if you're older
right well i've had it twice too and
everybody survived that we know
or it might just be bad luck i know a 32
year old that got the flu and went
septic and died and she was perfectly
healthy
sometimes happens what do you do
what do you do and this is what i'm
gonna tell you it's a highly contagious
real virus that's highly contagious
thanks to
the ccp okay so i'll put that out there
too and the wu on lab
but it's here and it's real and it's
coming for you
and it's going to get you but how do you
and you'll be able to grow your body
prepare your body for it that's okay to
say that
whether you think it's a flu or just a
strep throat it doesn't matter
it's here i've had it twice just prepare
your body and stop crying about it
vitamin d they said that everybody that
was admitted to the hospital
was extremely deficient in vitamin d
start pumping them full of vitamin d
lots of fluids uh and treat it like a
regular cold
you'll be fine where did the flu go this
way
this year i don't care what you call it
what you want what you want but i'm just
sick and tired of democrats being so
fearful
that they think if they get the vaccine
they're going to be completely immune
well we're finding out you're not
so what does that tell me i'm looking at
this as a numbers game
if you get the vaccine and you can still
get covet even if it's rare
you can still get covered yeah so you
better watch out
because it's coming for you just get
healthy that's all you can do
brett kavanaugh um
the supreme court the united states
rejected another plea
from religious americans to restore
their right
to free exercise or religion this time
concerning a christian florist in
richmond washington
i didn't even know christians were up in
the northeast
sometimes they they usually own business
it's a pretty pretty successful business
no it's the florist and she's hired lgbt
folks she knows people like that
however she said that you know what it's
my right
to deny service to anybody i want and
the local city says
no no not only bake the cake but now
you're gonna make the flowers
always supreme court and now we've got
kavanaugh
and um amy comey barrett
siding with liberals saying no
we're not even going to look at they
said we're not even going to look at it
you know what to you know what now i
remember hearing this yesterday
and but i don't know the whole story but
the only takeaway that i thought without
hearing
anything is that the supreme court is
like you know what you're not going to
feel this caught up with a whole lot of
this mess
yeah you know i mean you know what first
was the cake
now it's flowers next thing is gonna be
is plates
and we already ruled on gay marriage so
it's it's done folks
yeah you got you got garage it's all
over the place now
y'all look y'all just taking up our our
our docket with this stuff you know
whatever we're going to send it right
back
to watching it's still an infringement
it's still an infringement upon the
first amendment and their
religious rights in america
their right to say yes or no it's their
right
absolutely the government cannot tell
a business how to operate and run their
business i'm sorry
that don't work that way desantis didn't
flirt
to not infringe on people's rights yeah
sure
you can't require somebody to put on a g
odd
to come into your store you can't
require somebody
to wear a diaper to come into your store
you can't require that well
so how do restaurants and stores require
you to put on clothes
no shirt no shoes no service race that's
sanitary
that's sanitary it's for you can't go
and help in a place naked come on man
that's not appropriate
first remember though to go naked
if they want no it's decorum we live in
a society with rules and
we live in a society with we got naked
beaches they got naked beaches
they're not not where i live they don't
wrong no no
no where the naked beach is at okay but
forget
it's on the beach forget naked we're
talking about
uh the most places
mandatory you have to at least have on a
shirt
uh no you have to have one
you can't go in without flip-flops or
shoes
shoes shoes shoes and shirts
so first amendment
well i mean you can't make people put a
diaper on their face
but you can make people put on a shirt
and shoes
oh that's a society we live in though
that's appropriate this thing
the same thing with diapers that's not
appropriate
you have something up and beyond that's
above and beyond
do you have stupid it you know what
you know what i look i i
okay alan west is primary and primary
hmm primary that's that word
i don't even know if that's the real
word to use primary primary
greg abbott some people are looking at
this like now
when i was looking at the comments about
this one
they were like but he's
so many people were like well he's he's
done what he's supposed to do
now i know some people outside of texas
like well you know he took his time and
okay uh i don't know
if alan west is gonna i don't know
either
i don't know if he's craig abbott's not
hated i don't think
right i don't feel like he's hated but
they
were one of the first ones to go pro
open
were they not yeah yes and he
celebrated that yeah so this is alan
this is a quick allen west
okay that was real quick it was real
quick that was the quickest
west i've ever seen yeah it might be as
quick as how much he gets voted
for he basically said that he uh he
couldn't sit on the sidelines any longer
um and he made his announcement in a
campaign video during the 4th of july
appearance in sojourn church in
carrollton texas
and he says i have not been in office
for for a decade but i can no longer sit
on the sidelines and see what is
happening
in these united states what is happening
in the place that i call home
now again alan
i i i love and support you i just
i think this is going to get up against
the wrong tree right now i
i mean yeah he's reading the room wrong
uh yeah that
that room is reading wrong
but i mean it's teach it each his own if
you want to
run you can run nobody's stopping you
know
um bro is he buying his film looking
confused and forced to refer to his
notes while quiz by the media
and a michigan pasta talk to me it was
unbelievable he was at uh cash register
getting ready to pay for something
and and the fumbling around and and the
the lostness and the not understanding
and the woman asking him a question the
cashier asked him a question
and
and in the lockup and you know what you
know what i thought something was wrong
with you
is he is he frozen that's exactly and
then all of a sudden then i'll say
well
and he's pulling out all these notes and
the notes get even more lost he's even
more lost with the notes
and he's like i might get back to you on
that okay
yeah i mean and you know people can say
elder abuse and yes i agree his um
the people made sure that he ran they
knew he was sickly
uh he can barely walk um it's like
his shoes have tacks in him whenever he
walks i mean he
he's walking so generally so gingerly
and i know people are asking
from for him to have a cognitive
cognitive test
right and it won't happen the same thing
happened with trump
the same thing happened with barack
obama you know that
the uh because somebody came out and
said that brent uh that barack obama was
mentally ill
and uh people lost their minds and they
said that
they really lost their minds when they
said barack obama was mentally ill
so what did they do when trump got in
office they tried to make it
right what's wrong with me as i see so
many reporters covering up his mental
state
that's the issue if you had real
journalism
actually saying hey guys something's not
right with joe the more that they would
say it
there would be a movement there would be
something
the white house would have to respond to
it but they're honestly covering for
them
once you realize that the media is
working hand in hand with joe biden
then everything else to you well just
like they did with the clintons just
like they did with obama
i mean it's it's all the same yeah
um bubba and hanks
bubbanhanks.com
uh yeah give them a call get get the
meats
get the wagyu beef uh they
they were running a special before
fourth of july and they're still running
this special
um so if you
want wagyu beef they have so many
different types
of wagyu that you will definitely love
it
uh you can go to www.bubbandhanks.com
or call 361-218078
use promo code wayne yeah and we're in
the heart of summer
so obviously it's grilling season they
have anything from hamburgers
to steaks uh all different kinds of
things so make sure you take a look at
their website first before you just
get your mindset on what you're ordering
so go to their website take a look at it
and then uh you'll be able to order and
actually the prices are really good and
we actually confronted him he was on the
show a few weeks ago
we confronted him uh why
his meets were so i guess price so great
he said yeah he wanted it that way so
that way an average american person
could afford it
not just the rich uppity elites right no
gmos no hmos no
steroids or antibiotics um not only that
he takes such great care of the
livestock that the water that the
livestock drink is actually
filtered water same filter water they
use in the house
not not this not the sewage water out
there in the field
before before we go a little bit
a little slightly over but um before we
go uh
democrat told morning joe the capital
riot was worse than benghazi
this is the same narrative the sa you
know there's a whole lot of history
being rewritten
in the last couple weeks one of them is
this
another one is that the uh
republicans are for
defunding the police he's funding the
police i mean they are really doing that
they really said that they are they're
really pushing that
they're really pushing that and um
they're going back to
a bill or something that was on the
floor uh
a couple years ago uh where they might
have voted against
something for the police to pay increase
or something
or but it had to also deal with some
other
port that was also in the bill and but
but the democrats aren't letting you
know that one
they're just saying well they voted
against and
that's how a lot of people that's how
there's
a whole lot of things in washington dc
with legislation that never get done
because if this bill is supposed to be
for this to take care of you
then they start tacking on all this
other stuff the bill never gets passed
so then they can go in front of people
and say well y'all didn't pay
y'all voted down this i know but it had
all this other stuff
up here that you know it had it had
so much gunk and bump in here that
we couldn't pass it down right we
couldn't pass it
they said that january 6th is worse than
9 11.
it's worse than benghazi it's worse than
pearl harbor one thing they won't say
it's worse then
is covid because see they still gotta
run with the covet narrative
if if if january 6 was that detrimental
and that many people died on january 6
they would say it's worse than coven
but they won't because they just run
with this narrative because why
why do they want to push january 6 so
bad because they desperately cannot
afford to have trump
run and win in 2024. they have to do
everything possible to make sure he does
not get in once trump's not in
if he does not get in on 2024 you'll
never hear about january 6 again
but we have yet to even here we have yet
to even hear about january 6th yet
just get ready and buckle up because as
soon as election season starts heading
out
that's all you're going to hear about
january 6 january 6th that's
all you're going to hear joe biden said
in a speech just recently
that covent 300 000 dead
more than all the wars
in the 20th century more than all the
dead bodies
more than everything we've ever seen in
the last hundred years
three hundred thousand dead from covet
and i started
well i know i cause i'm i'm into history
and i'm really
i was raised in the cold war era and and
communism is
is alive and kicking it's not dead
and we just witnessed in the last
hundred years where communism was
responsible for
close to 200 million dead
and and joe biden's given a speech
saying 300 000
dead of covid more than all the wars
combined
yeah he's he's he's this is insanity
believe me he is he is so far but um
claire mccaskill who
she knocked her she numbed once is she
ohio was she ohio too
no i think she was i thought she was
miss was she missouri
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
right um
she hasn't been the same ever since she
lost it
veritas exposed her for being a liar
that she is
yeah she is she she's a major one but
uh this is the danger of
people like her getting on tv first
thing in the morning
everybody knows once when i was growing
up
and we're getting ready to leave y'all
getting ready to leave uh when i was
growing up
um when we were going to school
the bus driver would play his radio
on the way to school nine times out of
ten but
by by lunchtime the only like the music
that was in your head was what you heard
first thing in the morning okay that's
what i'm trying to get to
the first thing in the morning that's
why they put the most ridiculous
voices the most destructive voices
first thing in the morning uh uh
that's why they brow beat you in a
separate separatism
first thing in the morning so that when
you get to school
it's or or when you get to work
at the at the water jug place or whatnot
you're talking division type of things
of what's going on
and because of what you heard or whatnot
and that's
and that's how this country keeps on
being
built is off of these voices like claire
mccaskill
and all these other people who just want
to wreck it they just want to wreck this
country
and they don't talk about bringing
anything together
you don't hear nothing about joe biden's
unity thing anymore you
because that was never the plan i'm not
trying to bring this country together
it doesn't it doesn't work in our
interest
for this country to be together because
then
nobody's running to them begging him for
help yeah
we don't we wouldn't need them if if
racism was cured
we wouldn't need jesse jackson and al
sharpton if
if we came together as one america
then the federal government would
literally be what it was supposed to be
which is minuscule almost nothing we
would have all the power back to the
states
yeah we have to ask ourselves are we
strong enough to get through
some of these people that are pushing
the racial divide
are we strong enough to survive this
it's going to take every conservative
even republicans
to get on board and to fight back and i
think we're i think we need to give
ourselves a little bit more credit than
what we are
because i think we're doing a good job i
see people on twitter on our side
calling out the olympians
who decided to turn their back on the
flag at the soccer game
did you see that um yeah it was
sickening uh i'm
and then some are in denial oh no they
were facing the other way
face it with your team i don't give a
crap if there was another flag somewhere
else
stay with your team that's not a team
right if you're going the other way
the google says it never happened right
well of course google would say it never
happens right
but honestly i'll be honest with you if
you work as a team stay as a team
and that's how you should be out on the
field that is your job
behind the scenes i don't care where
you're turning back or what you're doing
but again it was sickening but we had
people on our side call it out we've
managed to make coca-cola sales the
lowest in history
because of their race issues so
again we're fighting back everybody pat
yourself on the back you're doing a good
job
but right now as joe biden would say
that's still something he says
keep your foot on the gas like felchi
says with covet keep your foot on the
gas
right now i want everybody to keep your
foot on the gas and keep going
because at some point their voices will
be muffled why do you think big tech
is trying to scrape and claw their way
out of the gutter to keep us
quiet at some point the jig is up for
all of them keep going you guys
you're doing a good job and i don't
think enough conservative news stations
conservative talk shows are saying that
enough to you
you are doing a good job keep it up
and i just gotta knock on my door at ups
they keep coming to deliver something
and he just
won't leave it at my doorstep so i'm
gonna put myself on mute and yell at him
drop a dog
wayne dupree make sure that you go there
uh
check out their uh their awesome gummies
uh they're awesome lotion my knee is
killing me today
uh i have i have their lotion actually
right here
takes me like four like 40 squirts you
know i
put it on my knee but i think there's a
little bit bigger internal
thing so uh that's why i'm breaking down
to go to the doctor next week
uh but it does work i mean for the
shoulder
that lotion is awesome i mean for
for a little back pains and aches and
pains takes care of it
one hundred percent so um we're asking
you to
visit cbd lion forward slash wayne
dupree for
20 off on your product
purchase 20 off they have tinctures
right there you
see a little tinctures there you you
could put them
in smoothies you could put them in
shakes you could put them in anything
uh but you don't have an addiction
of this thing and actually we're going
to try to get them back on so they can
talk some more about it you know
no it's real high-tech i mean this is
what these guys do this is their life
they dedicated their life
to this holistic natural way of reducing
inflammation
and as soon as you start to reduce
inflammation your body can actually
start to heal itself
that's the big big deal you you look
like you just
whip somebody's tail yeah you do you
look like you just kicked the hell out
of something i will tell you right now
ups i'm not real good friends with ups
right now
i'll be honest with you i'm not real
good friends wow all right
who knocks on the yeah you can see
the smoke
here's my last thought here's my last
thought if you work for ups
fedex if you work for any of them here's
my last thought if you knock on a
basement door
and expect someone to be able to hear on
the third floor of a house
because you're on the basement door
knocking and then you write a note sorry
we missed you and then it's a holiday
weekend and i needed my package before
the fourth
and you couldn't bring it because your
dumb bum didn't think about walking up
the front porch steps and actually
knocking on the real door
that's not my issue stupid
see you can't you can't help people like
that you can't fix it can't fix stupid
no
but you do look like you whip somebody
like this i did i wasn't real happy with
them
i'm a little revved up i wish the show
was another hour because i've got a lot
to say
she's look she tried to play it off too
she's like
okay it's all good it's nice it's all
good
try to calm down get back on really push
this
full spectrum because i'm loving that
lotion
the hold on let me say the photo
i yeah walk away
daniel said do you have any calm down
lotion
i actually like to be worked up i don't
like that calmness i like to be
revved up here we go no no no let's do
another hour let's rev it up baby
let's listen uh i usually
put quotes on my timeline if you brian
you right you got any last thoughts real
quick
if you haven't seen the series the
chosen i don't know what you're thinking
absolutely must see it the series the
chosen to
they're wrapping up the second second uh
season
this sunday it is a phenomenal series
with the likes i've never
ever seen before uh when it comes to the
life of jesus christ
uh last night we were watching going
through different old movies and we were
watching trailers for like
ben hur and and gone with the wind and
all these different movies and different
things that having to do
whether it be charlton heston or
something and i'm telling you it was a
whole nother era
in hollywood in the 60s where they made
good movies that really were family
uh god-fearing movies that were just
phenomenal
and this this mini sears this this
series the chosen
has absolutely uh outdone themselves
with that as well so
i love that that land that uh moon
landing movie
wow
breaking news fox news
[Music]
breaking news fox news is becoming well
not becoming
is adding a new channel fox weather
because because climate change that's
climate change
nation wasn't enough probably yeah you
all got fox nation
that's not why yeah it's not why it's
because it's not working i'm just saying
i'm just i'm i'm just being honest with
you it's climate change they have
the company is aggressively poaching
star meteorologists
okay in hoping to become a powerful new
player on the spear
long dominated by the weather channel
what uh whether the channel is doing a
damn good job
they know they're busy that is too
descriptive that whoever wrote that was
no that but the guy the founder of the
weather channel
does an excellent job of debunking and
slamming all liberals when it comes to
climate change
or maybe the global warming maybe
they'll get that gut you remember the
guy from the today show that would do
the smucker's birthdays of the day
remember the smuckers guy he would do
the smucker's jelly you guys don't
remember that you were
probably in school i was you mean the
one that had the the
uh stomach uh no that that's somebody
else
al roker yeah maybe they'll get al roker
i figured they were gonna do you know
what
why a weather channel that's perfect for
climate change of course they're going
to do that willard
willard scott they're also going to do
you know
yeah you can't live forever man
listen wait till they do the
infrastructure channel where all they do
is just put
videos and cameras on all the
infrastructure right because they're
going to push back
he's still alive yeah okay um
but usually if i usually put quotes
quotes hit me and then or i might see a
quote and then i might change it up a
little bit but
i came with a quote this morning and
uh this was before i got knocked out
um but i want y'all to
take this and use it however you want to
but uh
we'll be back tomorrow 12 p.m eastern
standard time
uh ships don't sink from the water
around them
ships ships think because of the water
they take on
wow so don't let what is happening
around you get inside of you to weigh
you down
confucius god bless confucius
yeah yeah confucius and stratos
all right uh thank you everybody for
tuning in
and right now
i am going to rest
again it's gonna be hot this afternoon
by the way
it's already smoking here it is lit it
was by 10 o'clock it was
lit it's gonna be like 96 97 degrees you
could go outside with a butter knife and
literally start carving
circles out of the air so yeah well i
went to go get my package just now the
ups guy had on a mask
outside 10 feet away from me and he was
just sweating and i'm like dude
profusely i'm sure wow did you call me
did you no i looked at him and i said
look i'm going to hurry he said you over
21. i said yeah
he said he said here you have to sign
this he said you have to sign this and i
said
okay but i'm in a hurry i'm trying to do
a show and i signed it
and i grabbed the box and i said yeah
wait till you actually see me in real
life like oh my gosh we go to these
conferences
i'm like five one and a half and i kind
of just walk around about you're about
to eye
with my wife hey brian you'll be like
leah
thank you i am so social
i've been married to my wife for 15
years now and i
i'm shocked everyone every time i'm
shocked
when i see somebody that's her height
and she stands next to them i'm like
that woman's short and my wife is
something happens look at people and
i'll
i'm froze
[Laughter]
no you know sometimes i look at people
and think oh my gosh they're so short
and then i'll be like oh i'm shorter
than them
you know real quick i had i was dating
this girl
that was really short really short
and i think what scared me what really
scared me about it
is i thought people would think that she
was my
daughter
you know i was like oh my god i mean she
was she had to be about maybe
four four nine maybe that's vertically
challenged leo that's
mitch it's illegal yeah she doesn't care
anymore i'm gonna start doing everything
politically wrong
everything i'm gonna be the most
offensive person
i'm gonna start tomorrow that's that
that sounds like george carlin too
hey what about the short people song my
husband always sings that to me
people with grubby little hands yeah
oh yeah it's a great song you got to
listen to it we sang it in course
in front of the school can you believe
it oh my gosh no i cannot believe that
way
does anybody out there know the short
people song well back in the 60s you're
allowed to get away with little hands
little eyes
in the 70s it's really in the 60s you're
oh okay whatever yeah
yeah listen to short people by randy
newman yeah
yeah yeah it was now they should be
canceled
but but just watching the parents go
yeah cause it's just about the cute kids
it was just a song it was just a song
all right all right bye-bye
[Music]
okay